first off puff pastry you can buy
fabulous puff pastry now a non-stick
baking tray and just lay the puff pastry
on the tray I want to get the top of the
puff pastry camera eyes so we're gonna
dust it in icing sugar now move for a
means a thousand layers just lightly
dust the top of the puff pastry with
icing sugar we're gonna start off in a
hot oven at 220 for the first six or
seven minutes and then ten minutes at
190 into the oven now for the filling
fresh vanilla cream in and start
whisking what the cream whisk
nice and thick but look at all that nice
fresh vanilla seeds in there next a nice
scraping of orange zest all right look
cure don't whisk that in fold it in and
that stops the cream separating lovely
now take that out of the bulb and put
into a piping bag unwrapped over your
hands in a way that your phrasing is
little pocket snip off the end nozzle in
load up your bag just twist slowly
there's no where the bag is nice and
full and firm chill your gorgeous
vanilla and orange cream in the fridge
until you're ready to pipe it wow that
is beautiful
there's the layers there that's the mill
for epub gently lift it up onto the
board
I'll slide into three serrated edge
knife
beautiful start deciding on how you
gonna layer it that bit there that's
nice and firm for my brace that's nice
and decorative for the top and that bit
there for the middle take our you cream
[Music]
and put a little touch of cream there
and that just sticks that down it stops
it from sliding pipe very carefully a
nice thin layer of cream round the
outside and come back into the middle
beautiful now there are Swiss sit them
two by two now this layer I'll turn it
upside down and put the camera eyes part
of pastry on top of the last place every
time I get to put one of these together
it's like a sort of little jewelry box
again cream squeeze from the back of the
bag so you got control there a Swiss too
much
I just want another layer of cream on
top those rasmus because I want some
height with my final layer well just
want to dive in there put the lid on it
mmm
push that down there you have a
beautiful stunning simple meal for a
dessert to die for and like all the
dishes in my ultimate cookery course I
guarantee it will taste as sensational
as it looks
[Music]
season and pour in a good glug of olive
oil then whisk now the exciting part
with address the sellers my spoon of
dressing in to the papaya